ah look who it is
look who it is
look pick up stupid
pick up pole
pick up the phone oh you've reached
hurricane okay [ __ ] it seriously
i know you're listening i could see you
in the chat
pick up the phone
this is the first time i've got big time
by a person that i actually know is
available and listening
i just got big time by somebody i just
got
[ __ ] big timed by a person
wow [ __ ] wow
hey cells rob [ __ ] joint [ __ ] you
you piece of [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you you know what it is you [ __ ] my
computer my computer crashed
because of you and i was calling you
this morning to apologize
to you no you weren't no you weren't you
were calling because you're upset
because you are basically running
uh a piece of rob bacon with an intel
penny and two processor
okay and be that as it may
[Laughter]
be that as it may my point is my point
still stands
the the actual fact that
honestly you know why the computer
crashed because of your shitty bacon i'm
gonna make the connection here for you
bud
um okay yeah and i'm going to i'm going
to make the connection for you
do the math because i was so [ __ ]
upset
upset at your shitty shitty bacon
i was so upset at your shitty [ __ ]
bacon
that i today didn't have the energy to
make sure my computer was running at
peak performance
and that's because i wasn't running a
peak performance
because you made shitty bacon
yeah next time i'm gonna cook you raw
ham well you know what
let me just do something here real quick
because i think this this will
this this should work hold on give me
hold on let me see if i got it
come on work please work for the love of
god work what
not you not youtuber that's not good i'm
like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you hey john look do me a favor
i have my buddy eric here on the phone
and he made like really bad bacon
and i made fun of him and i want you to
apologize to him because his bacon was
like basically raw can you please
apologize to him
oof all right all right first and
foremost before i go into this apology
how the [ __ ] do you [ __ ] up bacon thank
you
thank you go ahead apologize but
anyways so i digress you know
culinary experts a lot of us aren't them
none of us are gordon ramsay and you
know
sometimes in the kitchen it can be scary
you got these knobs you got an air fryer
if you don't have one i guess you're
you know a soy boy but i digress laptop
he has a style yeah and the slap
challenge so
anyways a lot of us rat discipline
so when we you know it's all learning
experience and
you know you didn't make bacon the first
time around that's okay
keep doing it again we got pigs we got
some we got so many pigs
even the ones that we eat and just i am
sorry
that the bacon was not edible
and i wish that we could just go on and
i and i the deepest deepest deepest
deeper sorry
that that that happened i am sorry now
uh eric that was a that was a
a sincere apology it sounded sincere
john do you think i should start again
should i try again should i get back on
that horse
absolutely get up hey if you want you
have may make make bacon out of that
horse if it makes you feel any better
i will die i don't want i don't want to
worry hold that thing here i don't want
horse bacon
i don't want horse bacon man john that
was a very kind apology
and i think i speak for myself and i
speak for eric when i say
i don't accept look i hung up on you not
accept that
i i won't accept that apology either i i
i listen i apolo i apologize to you for
that bad apology
i apologize to you for that you should
apologize for me for wasting my time
on having to hear that apology yeah you
know what it was a waste of my time when
it
was
your time and you know why this computer
crashes john's terrible apologies
and by the way i don't well eric i got
to make this clear to you and i'm sure
you got it but i have if i don't say
this i'm not going to sleep tonight
i don't want horse bacon
yeah that ship's already sailed buddy i
think we're having i
don't why no please oh please
i it's very important to me that you
know
that i do not want bake i like horses
and not eating them
oh please i don't we are manning the
sails on this the ship is leaving
i don't want horn i don't i
don't want horse bacon i would like
regular bacon
okay for a pig horse bacon okay
listen i promise you if i do pig bacon
it's gonna be raw if i do horse bacon
i'll cook it perfect now you have to
choose all right then horse bacon
um let me see something i'm actually
going to look this up i got to see if
horse bacon's real
i really do i get oh my god horse bacon
is real
holy [ __ ] people have made bacon out of
horses
what the [ __ ] man
somebody in china that eat horse sashimi
what the [ __ ]
they want raw horse too this is
disgusting
this is [ __ ] this is your fault eric
i would have lived the rest of my life
eating normal bacon
jesus christ you're welcome for
expanding your you know
culinary aptitude i have to ask you a
question and
this is a real question okay when you
cook that just
limp bacon did you just put it in the
freezer because i don't think it was
ever in the oven
i um you must not have heard it but no i
have the blow dryer out
is that that's how the pro that's they
do it on that's how they do it on
uh what was what was what was that show
where all the chefs competed against
each other
iron chef that's how they do it on iron
chef they use a blow dryer
alton brown taught me it's the truly a
child's method
alton brown taught me did you use him
it's a [ __ ] hair dryer
[ __ ] it does sound like something
they would do it
at a hipster restaurant but on the low
heat mode
yeah it's like something to do at a
hipster restaurant in winter garden
you know if i can oh no will you cook
our bacon with hair dryers
by the way not even an iron because an
iron would actually
work better no an iron would have gotten
the job done yeah
i don't want truck i don't know what's
making me laugh
but i'm just taking a bunch of hipsters
from the back with just hair dryers that
keep blowing the fuses
mustaches final t-shirts and blow dryers
oh [ __ ] by the way you know what else is
[ __ ] and you know you know food just not
bacon and i told you this
i don't like poached eggs [ __ ] is wrong
with po don't boil my eggs in water
i don't mind a hard-boiled egg when it's
cooked in a protective shell but i don't
want the inside of my egg to make
contact with water
yeah i don't know my wife is weird yeah
i know but [ __ ] poached
what's poached eggs who [ __ ] what is
that oh i wanna is anything
boiled except for pasta is any protein
boiled good
don't boil my food yeah please i don't
you [ __ ]
poached eggs i'll tell you this
poached eggs are communist propaganda
uh look at that people are mad [ __ ] you
guys in your poached eggs
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] you cook eggs on a
frying pan [ __ ]
well they're calling me baby tongue
lopez and that's not true actually i
have a very diverse palette
okay i don't i have a very diverse
palette and don't
don't call me that because it hurts my
feelings okay and these guys care about
my feelings so i don't think they're
gonna keep calling me baby tongue lopez
that's not them those are these these
aren't the type of people that hurt
feelings
they're better than that they're better
than [ __ ] better than that
i swear to god i'm buying a pack better
than them royce
nobody nobody nobody you know what i'm
going to do for you
i do ha i have a hair an extra hair
dryer because do i need one no
so i'm going to dude yes
i'm going next time i need two hair
dryers next time to get the bacon up
another third of a temperature no but i
really am gonna do this experiment i'm
really gonna do this experiment
i'm really gonna get one piece of bacon
and i'm gonna see if i could cook it
with a hair dryer
all right but make sure it's quick cut
don't be cheaping out maybe it's monster
it is it is you know what here that guy
hey marie can i borrow your hair dryer
it's not to cook bacon
uh take that as a yes i'm assuming
that's a yes
that would have to assume you're not
doing anything right now
i'm not it's just a cook bacon
okay thank you i'm gonna cook bacon i'm
gonna cook bacon with it don't tell her
um guys look i know you probably gotta
work or [ __ ] ruin somebody else's
meal whatever you gotta do
um so i will let you go but i just wanna
say thank you so much
um for graciously apologizing to me
about your bacon
it really means a lot to me it really
really does
um yeah yeah it's uh it's fine
i was happy to do it um you know i
i care very much about the people that i
cook for and uh
why you know i honestly honestly i
really just wanted you to shut the [ __ ]
up
what the [ __ ] dude what the are you
[ __ ] we were hey
oh [ __ ] he hugged about
i'm supposed to hang up on him
what the actual [ __ ] that's my [ __ ]
oh i'm mad oh
i'm angry
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ]
what yes jj what's up
hey royce yes big ham
says hi oh what the [ __ ] no
ah what's happening no
oh my god this is a hit job this is a
hit job
what is happening
close your mouth it makes you look
dumber that's the only way i know how to
look
big hams in the chat now guys this is
getting [ __ ] dicey i'm not gonna lie
to you i don't
i don't i don't we what's up man what's
up ag
what's up
hello yeah should i clip this part
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you ig mark wait
okay excuse me should have accepted the
ham baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] you frozen this is a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm getting what the [ __ ] dude
oh my god [ __ ] all of you [ __ ]
all of you i wake up every
[ __ ] morning to put a show on to be a
good person
and this is what you [ __ ] [ __ ] being
but this is
cyber bullying i'm calling the police
i am i am calling the police what
i just want to say i'm not sorry for
that
no no you piece of [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you
ah
what jj you should call the wamblance
no i'm not gonna [ __ ] that's not a
real fake stopper
i don't like this at all i i feel
first off this is cyber bullying i am
being cyber bullied
okay this needs to [ __ ] stop all of
you need a [ __ ] stop
i'm trying to put a show on and you guys
think this is funny
enough it's not we're done okay enough
you you got you all you all
had your laugh
you all had your fun okay
i lie to you you know my bets are fun
when i do them to other people
i don't really like when you do them to
me so don't
please don't do them to me
very simple
don't
[ __ ] dicks whoa
look at that you know it could have
solved all your problems my good friend
royce
except the ham
what what jade what hail happy cold
what it's a hamspiracy
shut up shut up shut up
[ __ ] up
i'm sorry i'm getting legitimately
scared with this hand [ __ ] now
i really didn't think i don't know what
[ __ ] pandora's box of [ __ ]
pork i opened but i don't like this
i don't know if you guys know this but
you're picking on me
oh er okay well eric you could call back
if you're kondo apologize you could call
back that's fine
i will accept people calling to
apologize that that is fine
if you're calling to apologize i will be
accepting your calls don't worry about
it i'll be accepting it
i if you're trying to make good i will i
will do that so let's see
hey hey eric hey first off lower your
radio
uh and eric even though it's a computer
yes
it's you even though it's your your
voice okay so what's up
uh listen um all seriousness man uh i
never
wanted to do that to you thank you you
know i know you wake up every day and
you work really really hard to bring us
entertainment thank you
and uh you are you know you're a god
amongst men
thanks and it's all i ever wanted to be
i i i'm a simple mortal man
and the money that was
given to me by by big ham was was just
too much and i couldn't
i couldn't look past it wow and i had to
join their ranks
but but i can assure you that uh i it
will never happen again
i should be loyal thank you and and i
will i will
i will never give you a taste of your
own medicine again but
that thank you so much i i appreciate it
that really means a lot to me
um and big ham also ironically owned by
wow i mean it makes sense it's crazy
right
but hey thank you for the apology that
really really mean that really means a
lot
that really means a lot good and i hope
so i hope i hope you can
forgive me find it in your heart one day
um and i hope you can
you know move on with your show and do
great things
any last thing you want to say to the
fans because i seem to like you for
[ __ ] pranking me
uh no man uh i i appreciate it ah
[ __ ] you i got you this time [ __ ] you i
got you i don't accept your apology at
all
it was a ruse it was a giant ruse
piece of [ __ ] what
hold on let me turn my my radio down uh
aren't you the guy that said never to
apologize
i don't like this at all i really don't
this isn't fun
anymore this this show
for computer crashing was bad enough but
all of this stuff
what what yes aj what's up bud uh so i'm
gonna go ahead and clip this because
this
this makes you look no no no don't clip
this no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
[ __ ] me
can we move on i i'd like to do
something else that doesn't involve me
being the joke
clip something else man
[Music]
[ __ ] you closer you're hamming it up
[ __ ] you closer
[ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you
[ __ ] what zipper
what yeah if you don't [ __ ]
mute your mic i can't hear you stupid
sorry have world order i don't
i don't really i don't i don't i don't
like this
i i don't know i don't like this i don't
like this at
all